Is Disney sticking by the all new, very blue
Genie?
Or is the House of Mouse already denouncing
its own creation?
The company kept quiet after the internet
completely torched Will Smith following the
newest live-action Aladdin trailer drop, but
now, Disney has come forward to address the
blue Genie debacle.
It wasn't long ago that Disney summoned up
the second trailer for its upcoming live-action
remake of Aladdin, an updated version of the
1992 animated classic from director Guy Ritchie.
But the very vocal response to the trailer
from online viewers may have caught studio
executives off guard — especially the reaction
to the Genie reveal money shot.
Some people must have liked it, but the consensus
seemed clear:
"Terrible…"
In addition to the new face of the Genie,
the sneak peeks of movie have brought audiences
their first glimpses of fresh-faced actor
Mena Massoud as Aladdin, the scrappy street
rat who sweeps a royal princess off her feet
with the help of a few white lies and a magic
flying carpet.
That princess, Jasmine, is being played by
Naomi Scott, who you may recognize from the
cast of the 2017 Power Rangers movie.
The previews for the movie have also offered
looks at the fictional city of Agrabah, as
well as a glimpse of Marwan Kenzari as the
movie's nefarious Grand Vizier, Jafar.
Perhaps most recognizable is the glittering
Cave of Wonders, and the ever-important golden
lamp that sits within it.
But, much to many peoples' dismay, the most
terrifying image from the second sneak peek
is a brief, kind of I can never unsee that
moment of actor Will Smith as the Genie a
blue-skinned magical being who looks... um…
bluer in real-life than anyone could have
thought possible.
Viewer responses were not great.
"I HATE IT!"
After the internet dragged Smith and the remake's
new Genie look, Disney kept quiet.
What might happen, now that the company knew
people were rejecting this important investment?
Would they address the hate, or keep their
lips sealed until the movie came out?
Could they tweak their approach to the Genie,
maybe by making him look a little bit more
real?
That remains to be seen.
But for now, the company has come forward
to at least address the big blue Genie debacle.
In a statement released to USA Today, a little
over a week after the second teaser saw release,
Disney defended Smith's Genie in broad terms
without getting into the specifics of viewers'
shocked reactions.
Reactions that ranged from "that looks scary,"
or "that looks fake," to...
"Wow, that's… so gross."
The company attempted to beat the bad buzz
by affirming its confidence in both the new
interpretation of the Genie character, and
the live-action Aladdin project as a whole.
The statement read,
"We have one of the most anticipated films
of the year and are confident that audiences
will fall in love with the Genie and all of
the characters when it hits the big screen
this May."
It's not exactly a shocker that Disney is
sticking to its guns with Smith's Genie.
It'd be more surprising if they actually agreed
with the criticism.
What else are they supposed to do, cancel
the movie?
"What?
No.
I mean, maybe."
Despite the lousy first reactions to one of
the film's main characters, there's plenty
of Aladdin that we've simply yet to see meaning
there's also hope that the Genie could work
just fine in context so long as people are
still willing to give the movie a shot.
But considering all the skepticism in the
air around these teasers, that's no guarantee.
Whether audiences are hype for it or not,
the film's creative team is likely putting
all available resources into ensuring the
live-action Aladdin is as shining, shimmering,
and splendid as it possibly can be.
It's just a project with a lot to live up
to especially for Smith, taking over a role
first embodied by the late, larger-than-life
Robin Williams.
It's possible that audiences were going to
judge Smith harshly no matter what approach
the filmmakers took, holding his performance
to a high standard whether the effects looked
flawless or not.
The former Fresh Prince has enormous shoes
to fill, but you can't say that he's not trying.
As he said in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly,
"...I got to sing, I got to rap, I got to
dance, I got to do action sequences — it
was everything that I've trained and learned
how to do over the last 30 years of entertainment
and I got to it use all in playing the Genie."
Maybe the Genie's weird looks will keep people
from getting on board with the remake.
Or maybe the world will be as charmed as Princess
Jasmine on a magic carpet ride.
To find out what happens, we'll simply have
to wait until Aladdin arrives in theaters
on May 24.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.